so i was
reading your book and there's just
something that i wanted to point out
because i just it really really spoke to
me it's the dedication
and it says here if you're reading this
book it's dedicated to you
i love that
so much thank you
well it's a book it's really a book
about you know i i write humor books but
uh i got coveted early on and i was
really sick and
it's really how i coped during covid
with my family and
i felt that whoever read this book as we
all
went through this global pandemic there
is sort of something for everybody in
there so
it's something i felt that we all went
through together so that's why i
dedicated it like that and it's also a
global pandemic so i'm hoping this will
be translated into turkish and arabic
and all the languages as it should as it
should be everybody needs to laugh and
you're so funny you keep us laughing um
but let's go into a vision
fly on the wall moment of you
and your husband george
mid covid i heard you guys were watching
love island
yeah let me
i'm married to not george clooney as
everybody thinks
george stephanopoulos who is a
a very smart brilliant rhodes scholar
yeah
like a clapping award-winning
journalist yeah political advisor yes in
the eye of the tornado of politics for
decades yes but something happened in
kobet i think to all of us where you
kind of went down to your base level and
my two daughters kept running in and
saying guys you've got to watch love
island australia
and we were like what what what are you
talking about one of them was like it's
just about people that hook up and then
they get voted off an island i was like
well i'm in
and
very shortly george stephanopoulos was
hooked to love island australia to the
point where
he was going i mean it was almost like
if you've ever seen him on election
night he's calling things like a
journalist so he would say like wait a
second so they had sexual intercourse
but she's actually smitten with him and
we were like oh i guess if you want to
put it that way
and we got so hooked on it that one
night we had a love island australia
dinner party
the four of us and we had to wear
bathing suits and makeup yeah
so there's one photo which no one can
ever see or george will leave me but um
and nor do you want to see me in a
bikini during covet but i had bikini
heels full-on makeup we could only speak
with an australian accent oh my god
that's so funny it was so fun and yet so
crazy so you got into themes talk to me
about mad men did you
like binge the whole show yes i did for
the second time in my life so you're
watching yeah so i'm watching don draper
who is a alcoholic flanderer in the show
yes and so and you love them all the
more for it of course those things you
want him even more and i was sick as a
dog i had coped very early on in march i
had a really high fever and this was
when you quarantined for three weeks and
so my whole family was downstairs i was
up in this room like the movie the room
for three weeks straight and
i got so loopy that i
thought that i was married to don draper
and
and george my husband came in one day
with the mask and the gloves and you
know gave me my soup and bread like i
was in prison and
i yelled at him and i was like if you
think sleep me with one of your
secretary and he was like oh my god
you're crazy you were crazy when i
married you you're crazier now george
was just like
he called our doctor and he was like is
she's delusional is that part of the
thing and even seeing the picture of him
now is like harkens you right back it
does i go that's my ex-husband drew i
don't want to talk about that exactly
[Music]